bon bout bonjour il ya vous devant la
grille et
je vais les des études aux beaux-arts de
poitiers
j'ai fait oui j'ai commencé de première
année là et j'ai fait les trois autres
dernières années à tour l'école des
beaux-arts de tours et un depuis 2007 6
7 et la sculpture surtout après dance
forment un petit peu j'ai été faire une
formation à l'afpa de châtellerault de
soudure parce que je savais soudé omid
mais pas à la baguette
ben en fait c'est chez comme l'écriture
automatique c'est un dessin qui vient
comme ça très vite sans réfléchir en
petit et puis les choses avaient arrive
un peu comme dans un rêve d'une façon un
peu bizarre aléatoire et puis je
construis en assemblant pour que les
dessins puisse après devenir des
sculptures si possible voilà et puis
après j'ai rempli des carnets
montier et puis je choisis
soit en fonction et dessins pour une
sculpture soit en fonction de la phrase
que je vais trouver pour un dessin faut
que la phrase à soi c'est percutante et
drôle et à ce moment là je la gardais je
suis passé au coloriage
et puis je les ai grandi
plus grands comme ça
et puis ceux qui n'ont pas forcément une
phrase rigolote mais qui sont
intéressantes au niveau des singes en
fait des maquettes
vaste échelle là
et puis j'en fais plusieurs et de ses
maquettes genre sélectionne encore
celle qui me semble le plus
faisable aussi techniquement
voilà on en acier acier donc assemblé et
soudée
découper avant au laser au classement et
soit sereine cran
en 50 60 cm la plus grande que j'ai fait
en acier c'était 2 mètres 50 là c'était
donc un magasin de mode japonais de mode
de luxe oui travailler surtout avec des
français les artistes français et donc
toute la décoration du magasin et aient
été faits par des artistes français donc
il cherchait quelque chose pour leurs
escales et alors moi je n'ai pas du tout
pensé à l'escalier c'était un peu comme
ça une cloison et mais après la toison
on peut partir sur une porte sur
sur mon portail à partir de mes dessins
sous titres et j'ai fait des ateliers
pour enfants avec des petites cartes
comme ça avec les dessins
et devait associer la phrase qui allait
avec
ou alors il partait d'un dessin comme ça
que je leur distribuer et devait
inventer la phrase et puis après ils ont
aussi il avait la phrase mais il fallait
qu'il fasse le dessin
voilà des exemples
ça s'est infligé un pyjama col des
timbres la tête en bas premier que j'ai
fait et j'ai fait en normandie mais
j'aimerais bien en faire d'autres voilà
donc c'est bien pour
pour faire travailler leur imagination
mais qu'ils un atelier d'écriture et de
dessin en même temps